[Música]
nosotros continuamos los altos precios
del mercado inmobiliario la inflación y
las elevadas tasas de interés hacen que
cada vez menos personas se interesen en
comprar vivienda y por tanto opten por
los alquileres de propiedades no
obstante se enfrentan a una problemática
que no es nueva pero va en aumento sobre
todo en ciudades turísticas o emergentes
en este ámbito son desalojados para que
los propietarios puedan ofrecer las
residencias en aplicaciones de tipo
airbnb donde la rentabilidad es más alta
para analizar este fenómeno conectamos
con Alejandro Díaz él es candidato a
doctor en derecho del instituto de
investigaciones jurídicas de la UNAM
Bienvenido a France 24 ampliemos En qué
consiste este fenómeno que si bien Es
legal podría generar una afectación
importante a los residentes de ciudades
Muchas gracias Valentina un gusto estar
aquí sí Yo diría que este fenómeno tiene
como punto de origen de un par de
décadas en procesos que se han llamado
financiación de la vivienda es decir son
procesos específicos fenómenos globales
en los cuales la vivienda ha sido
capturada por los mercados financieros o
ha cambiado también la concepción de la
vivienda y ha pasado de ser un derecho
fundamental un derecho social hacer una
mercancía y más recientemente otra cara
de ese mismo fenómeno sería Cómo se está
utilizando la vivienda ya no solo como
una forma de transacción sino también
como un servicio y ahí es donde aparece
las plataformas de alquiler de corto
plazo como airbnb como way o como
booking entre muchas otras son
plataformas que están presente en
dos países en el mundo y que empiezan a
tener efectos sobre modificación de las
dinámicas de los barrios empiezan a
incrementar los precios de los
alquileres del mercado regular de
vivienda del mercado de alquiler de
largo aliento y empiezan por supuesto a
generar algunos procesos de
gentrificación y modificación de Los
costos de vida y dinámica comunitaria de
los propios barrios Valentina bueno Y si
hacemos una radiografía de América
Latina Cuál es la situación en el
continente es decir dónde ocurre con más
frecuencia este fenómeno
bueno en un principio pudiéramos pensar
que las grandes ciudades que son
ciudades turísticas no tienen un mayor
atractivo para
efectivamente para que los grandes
capitales o simplemente
las personas que quieran generar
ganancias con este tipo de plataformas
instalen no viviendas sus viviendas en
alquiler de corto plazo y justo en estos
centros más explotados ciudades grandes
o ciudades pequeñas pero que son muy
turísticas Yo diría que además eso en un
principio pero hemos visto que inclusive
este fenómeno ha mutado de una manera
muy particular y ya no es solo grandes
espacios turísticos sino podemos ver
otro tipo de mecanismos emergentes que
se están utilizando en barrios por
ejemplo precarizados vemos las favelas
que se están instaurando estas
plataformas para ofertar esta especie de
experiencias turísticas en varios que
están sufriendo esa precarización de la
precarización No
justamente no sorprende que en principio
pues este fenómeno ocurría en las zonas
más apetecidas y en los barrios más pues
mejor ubicados como como lo podría
pensar con más recursos pero ahora pasa
hasta está pasando Incluso en sectores
apartados en sectores más silenciosos
usted lo estaba mencionando que antes no
eran considerados atractivos podemos
verle algo positivo a este fenómeno al
poner el foco sobre esas zonas
bueno el problema fundamental es que no
podemos realmente ser optimistas sobre
los beneficios que esto tiene porque la
concepción de la economía colaborativa
de estas plataformas Es simplemente una
forma de transacción una forma de
adquirir ganancias una forma de
enriquecimiento no y es poco el
beneficio que puede obtener a nivel
comunitario porque en realidad el está
una simplificaciones muy importantes
para las dinámicas comunitarias y nos
estamos jugando también la
lo lo importante el centro de
de no perder el foco que la vivienda es
un derecho fundamental no
bueno y justamente al respecto que está
pasando entonces con los locales son
desalojados y tienen que ceñirse de
alguna manera a un presupuesto de
vivienda según sus ingresos
claro hay que recordar también que de
acuerdo al derecho internacional los
desalojos forzados de personas y la
pérdida de vivienda a través del
desalojos está prohibida por el derecho
internacional en principio y está
prohibida por la por la legislación de
Derechos Humanos porque genera un una
cascada de violaciones de Derechos
Humanos profundas la pérdida de vivienda
da lugar también a varias situaciones
relacionadas con peligro la integridad
personal Peligro en la propia vida
Peligro en la dinámica familiar Y por
supuesto en la salud Entonces desde
luego que es importante que los estados
los países especialmente de nuestra
región de las Américas empiecen a
desplegar obligaciones más fuertes sobre
supervisión y regulación de
los plataformas de las plataformas de
alquiler a corto plazo y en general
generar un enfoque de Derechos Humanos
para que podamos aumentar los niveles de
protección y de seguridad de tenencia de
las personas que pueden estar peligrando
de perder vivienda a través de estos
fenómenos Pero entonces justamente le
preguntó en estos momentos hay alguna
garantía legal para las personas que
están siendo desalojadas
Desafortunadamente
la regulaciones específicamente
de las plataformas de alquiler en corto
plazo especialmente en América Latina
están reducidas a políticas Fiscales es
decir a cobro de impuestos de las
plataformas incluso ha habido grandes
ciudades como la Ciudad de México que
han firmado convenio de colaboración con
estas entidades sin transparencia y no
sabemos Qué efectos podrá tener esto en
corto plazo pero
desafortunadamente las políticas no
están siendo enfocadas en garantizar la
protección legal aumentar los niveles de
de protección y especialmente de
regulación para que sea en algunas zonas
incluso sea desincentivado el que estas
plataformas aparezcan no bueno algo que
se puede decir es que con el panorama
actual
se ve algún algún techo para para esta
práctica es decir en algún momento va a
frenar o que tendrá que hacerse en el
futuro son la solución son nuevas y más
estrictas regulaciones
sí fundamentalmente necesitamos pasar a
que las autoridades de los estados de la
región ejerzan cumplan con sus
obligaciones de Derechos Humanos
especialmente de derecho a la vivienda
adecuada sobre obligaciones de
supervisión fiscalización de entidades
privadas bajo la obligación del deber de
proteger violaciones de Derechos Humanos
cometidas por particulares y empiecen a
modificar regulaciones especialmente
para proteger a los más desfavores
desfavorecidos y a quienes podrían
peligrar su su vivienda puede ser desde
medidas de disminución o de la aparición
en ciertas zonas de las ciudades de este
tipo de plataformas puede ser también la
reducción el número de días posibles
para que una persona pueda poner su
vivienda en airbnb Y por supuesto
regulaciones fuertes
a la especulación inmobiliaria también a
algunos procedimientos de gentrificación
de las ciudades y fortalecer
Especialmente los mecanismos de
seguridad legal de tenencia de la
vivienda pues Alejandro usted muchas
gracias por su análisis y por
compartirlo con nosotros en France 24
muchas gracias a ustedes también Les
agradecemos que continúen con nosotros
vamos a hacer una breve pausa y
regresamos para nuestro último bloque
aquí en directo América
[Música]